this is exactly what I did to make my
first $10,000 online and I'm going to
walk you through how I got my first 10
customers what I did right what I did
wrong so that you can copy me so I had
always been into fitness from the time I
was 13 14 years old I was already
lifting weights and was really into it
in college was the vice president of the
powerlifting team and then I had my
consulting job and I talked about
Fitness all day long I read articles all
day and so much so that the people I
worked with were like dude if you don't
get into fitness will front you the
money to do this because you don't stop
talking about it and so I enough people
around me that I was like okay maybe I
am going to do this and so that's what
created the free training project and so
the idea was I would ask people to
donate $500 to $1,000 to the charity of
their choice and an exchange I would
train them for 3 months for free it was
free because they didn't pay me but they
still had to donate to something they
cared about but the thing that really
made it click for me where I was like
you know I'm going to do something here
is that there was this lady at my gym
named Sandy Smith and she saw me working
out and I was on the powerlifting team
in my local area and I was competing and
I had other guys who were competing
there too and it was clear that we knew
we were doing something well so she
asked me cuz I looked the least
intimidating because I was the most
jacked that's why I looked the least
intimidating she said hey can you help
me with my food and I was like sure and
she said well meet me at uh a pizza shop
and you can talk to me about my food
which is just hilarious I meet her at
the pizza shop and we talked for like an
hour and a half about you know it's like
hey try buy these things instead of that
you know maybe get more protein in this
is the stuff that I like I walk through
everything and I was happy to do it cuz
I just like talking about Fitness stuff
and at the the end of the conversation
she reaches down to her purse and she
puts her purse on the table and then she
reaches in and she grabs her checkbook
and she writes a $100 check to me and
the check was literally this big it was
a clown check and I was like why are you
a clown why am I a clown is this a joke
to you is this my passion something that
means nothing no I'm kidding none of
that was true but she wrote me a check
for 100 bucks and she was like thanks so
much and she slid it across the table
and she gave it to me and then she
walked out and I remember being like
holy [__] I can make money doing this I
was like that's pretty cool and so that
was like the light bulb moment for me to
say like I'm going to actually go from
this is a passion to I want to make this
something I make profit from so there's
four stages that I went through in order
to get to my firstand customers so the
first stage I started with was homies
reach out to the people who know you and
like you and so for me honestly all I
did was I took out this amazing piece of
technology which is my phone and then I
looked through my contacts leads reached
out to a handful of my friends and I got
about six of them is to say yes I will
let you me for free because we're
friends and you need before and after
pictures and that's pretty much all I
did it wasn't really that hard because
people knew that I loved Fitness and I
just said I'll help you for free and be
a homie and they said sure and so the
reason I started with homie specifically
was because I needed before and afters I
needed testimonials I needed results cuz
I figured if anybody was like me they
would think well sure maybe you say that
you can do that but why should I believe
you and so I solved really over the top
and this had it maybe I lucked into it
the first time but I have done it with
every single business I have ever
started which is get proof before
anything like if you have 100 pieces of
proof and a terrible offer versus an
amazing offer and no proof the guy with
100 pieces of proof is going to win you
don't even need that many pieces of
proof for people to believe you you need
proof that is similar enough to them
that they will believe that what you did
for that person will also work for them
and so the testimonials that I had I had
one guy who lost 50 lb I had a girl who
lost 50 lb I had a guy did like a
recomposition he stayed the same weight
but like looked crazy different
afterwards and so that kind of like
covered a handful of different avatars
for me later now that wasn't on purpose
that just kind of worked out to who
responded to me and they all had
different goals but it worked to show
that I knew what I was doing after I had
my homies this took me like six months
so mind you it's like I will take three
minutes in this video to explain it but
it was six months of my life and if
you're like man I want to get rich in
six seconds that's amazing wait for
stage four cuz I'll tell you how what I
would have done differently to make this
happen faster but the second step I did
was I asked them for referrals referrals
are the most important type of marketing
for a variety of reasons number one
referrals are free and so if you are
poor great place to start number two
referrals have higher likelihoods of
buying at higher prices so that means
you these leads are worth more than
every other type of lead because they
have a higher conversion rate and at
higher prices which is Banger third
reason that they're also more valuable
leads is that people who come from
referral are also more likely to refer
and so the way that you come in is the
more likely way that you will get
somebody else to to come in for all
those reasons referrals are sweet the
big picture reason that referrals are so
important when you're starting is that
if you're not getting any it means
you're not that good and so you don't
want to let more people know you suck so
instead you want to let as few people
know that you suck until eventually
people find out about how good you are
which is the right thing then you can
pour gas on the fire and do all the
other ways of advertising and so for
those of you who are starting out who
are really just at the very beginning
here then I want to give you what I wish
I knew and believe it or not we're
actually running this as a little
experiment inside of school right now
and the results are astounding I'm not
going to share the stats yet but they're
really really good we took the rule of
100 for warm outre and we've actually
kind of like broken it down into
something a three-step process that's
really tactical uh they're calling it
the rule of 300 and if you don't know
what the rule of 100 is which I talk
about in my$ 100 million leads book it's
the fundamental process of applying 100
repetitions to any of these things so
100 warm out reaches means you need to
reach out to people who know you mind
you doesn't have to be your homies like
you probably have 300 for you know
friends on Facebook and 500 followers on
Instagram or whatever all you know 300
people inside of your cell phone like
those are all the people you know you
reach out 101 to 100 plus cold prospects
people who don't know you you spend 100
minutes making content and then you post
that content to be clear you don't just
spend 100 minutes making content and do
nothing you post it and then finally you
can spend $100 a day on ads at minimum
all right that's how you get started
obviously you can spend more on ads but
you should spend at least 100 minutes
making the ads researching looking at
hooks recording Etc but if you do that
every single day you will get customers
because you will let people know that
you exist now the rule of 300 it's
really just taking the 100 the rule of
100 for warm Outreach and breaking it
down into three steps so I'll break down
all three for you right now so number
one is you post content just make a post
all right one piece on one platform very
simple all right you don't need to over
complicate this after you make the post
you do 100 comments all right this is
really big now the comments my
recommendation is you do it inside of a
group or Community now the reason that
we do it inside of a group is that one
it's going to be a pool of all of your
ideal customers and the goal of the
comments is to make the best comment all
right so if you look at all the comments
that are on someone when you make it as
a comment inside of a group there's two
benefits that you haven't might not have
thought of one is that inside of a group
you're not competing against everyone
you're now just competing against
everyone inside the group secondarily
you're not competing against everyone
even inside the group you're competing
against everyone in the comments and so
it makes you look like you're super good
even though you're just this much better
because you actually took a minute to
make a comment rather than just like
cool stuff or awesome right that's not
going to do it you have to put out
thoughtful response to each post now the
posts that you do you should just use
them as prompts so it should be a lot
easier for you to come up with comments
than to come up with content all right
so that's the second step now the third
step is that we now basically apply the
rule of 100 to our new warm list you're
like what's the new warm list so this is
like a it's like lukewarm it's like
right between cold and warm and so what
it is is everyone who liked your post
anyone who commented on your post and
anyone who
liked any of your comments now this is
going to be a pretty big one or replied
to your comment all right so that
basically gives you four different
sources to find the leads that you do
your one-on-one Outreach so this should
hopefully solve the big like who do I
reach out these people these people and
the reason we did this and this is key
the reason that we go after these four
people is because these four categories
have all done one thing which changes
them from strangers they have taken an
action they've indicated interest and so
the point of advertising which I Define
in the leads book is to go from an
unengaged lead which is just a person
you can contact to an Engaged lead which
is a person you can contact who has
shown interest in the stuff that you
sell or at least has shown interest in
you with that this sounds really minor
but it's huge you can then begin the
conversation by saying hey saw you like
my my content what about it drew you in
or like what made you do that or oh that
was so cool of you whatever hey I saw
you commented or thanks for that comment
and question right don't just say thanks
for the comment that's not going to
start a conversation you ask a question
what made you do that are you looking to
get in shape clean your house get
organized whatever the thing your
content was about hey I uh saw that you
liked my comment are you looking to
right and so anybody who's following the
type of content that you're commenting
on by the way duh comment on like if
you're selling dog stuff comment on dog
stuff don't comment on you know crypto
make money stuff and try and find dog
people now then again who knows but if
I'm going to pick where I'm like if I'm
going to pick where I'm going to make my
comments I'm going to Target posts that
already have the types of people that I
want to sell to commenting and posting
on it all right and then finally people
who reply to your comment are going to
probably be some of the warmest leads
because they've already read the thing
took the time to they already basically
messaged you in a way by by replying to
your comment so this if you think about
this is like we only need a 100 if you
make a post and you get 25 likes it's
like boom there's my first 25 reach outs
then I've got people who commented maybe
I've got three or four comments okay
there's another three or four then I
make myund remember remember here so
let's let's link these up so these two
go to this and then these two go to this
one let's see if I can cross the chasm
here there so if you then do a 100
comments you're going to at least get a
100 likes or responses because if you
actually take that much time the person
who you even who made you made the post
on will likely take the time to like
your comment because they want to
encourage other people to leave long
thoughtful comments like that this is
oneone Le gen for you not having any
audience so it's gone like you have no
more excuse this works and the results
that we're getting are [__] awesome
which I'm really stoked about I'll share
the stats later we're doing as a a big
experiment and there's one more reason
that I I think this is really sexy
comments on a big post will get way more
reach than your initial content
especially if you're starting from zero
because you basically get to piggyback
on the reach that other people's content
gets and so it's in a in a weird way
it's almost like you running mini ads
now to be clear you want to have
thoughtful comments you don't want to
say like buy my [__] like that will one
probably get you blocked by the person
whose content it is but also you look
like a shitthead so don't do that so you
want to have a thoughtful response and
this will take time to be clear like
well how many hours a day will this take
and notice I mentioned hours a day it'll
probably take you two to four hours to
do this every day but objective number
one when you're starting out is let
people know you exist because no one
does so I asked my homies after getting
them results so I provided Value First
and I said hey man I've got your before
and afters I need like a few more can
you send me some friends that have seen
your results and a lot of them had like
people were telling them like dude you
lost 50 lbs you look awesome or like hey
you look you have a bikini now like you
didn't even want to go outside without
covering yourself up like this is great
and so I got probably another 6 to 10ish
referrals from those first six and a
totally different thing happened here
these people didn't know who I was they
just knew that IID helped their friend
out and these people cared way less
about like helping me and cared way more
about just helping them which
unsurprising fine but the thing that
happened was because it was free none of
them really did anything and so that
became a problem and so then I was like
shoot that whole thing didn't work so
then I moved on to stage three which was
the free train TR in project and so that
is the title that we owe this section to
and so what I did was I said hey now
when you refer someone just donate $500
to ,000 to the charity of your choice
that way you still have skin in the game
but it's still effectively free in that
you're not paying me and so I was then
public about it people were like this is
awesome and then a lot of people came in
to support the fact that I was kind of
doing this for charity but long term I
wanted to find a way to turn this into
something that I can make money from and
so the next phase of customers this gave
me everything that I needed to then
transition to paid and so from there I
went to the skinny to swole project now
publicly this was a year later and so
this was where I asked new people to pay
$200 a month for 12 weeks to go from
skinny to swo and I had all these great
transformation pictures from my friends
from the people went through the free
training project to then do skinny to
swall and I was able to transfer and
this is a key point I was able to
transfer people from the free training
project into skinny to swall Without
Really losing many of them I just said
hey you know how you paid for weeks to
this charity want to pay me instead
whatever you paid them and they were
like sure I didn't really care because
again all these people they came because
their friends got results they were like
this is weird that this guy's making me
donate to a charity but I guess it's
fine they just cared about getting in
shape but that was me overcoming my own
like fear of charging for making money
and so that is when I got to my first 20
clients in skinny to swo which is me
posting and then reaching out to
everyone else I knew with all the
testimonials from the first three stages
to say hey I'm now officially launching
this thing and I got 20 guys to pay $200
a month and that was my first $4,000 per
month and that was for 12 weeks and that
was my first 12 Grand now you might be
like wait where's the so what what do I
do if I'm you well let me tell you what
I would have done if I knew everything
that I know now so here's bonus number
five I'll put little little stars around
it what would I have done if I knew what
I know now great so that's what this
section is there are a lot of different
businesses that you can potentially
start the reason that I think for
beginners starting an online service
business is the easiest one to start is
because it costs the least amount of
money and it has a lot of good economics
around it meaning it costs almost
nothing to deliver there's low recurring
overhead you can do it from any place in
the world if you're watching this video
you already have all the technology
required and so like basically
everything is there for you to start and
you get to learn all of the mistakes
that you're going to inevitably learn on
a low stakes business first hey and I
want to write you a check real quick and
not just any kind of check but one that
you can actually take to the bank and
this is about starting a school
Community the reason that I decided to
become a co-owner and made a massive
investment in school of the platform is
because for four years I was looking for
what is the easiest business online that
I can help people get started because I
have a massive amount of my audience are
business owners that you do do one five
10 100 million plus a year and that's
who watches my stuff and I have a lot of
deeper content for really tactical stuff
once you're at 20 employees 50 employees
100 employees 250 employees but if
you're just starting out then it's like
yeah that stuff's amazing but what do I
do today and so I want to give you this
check because this check is what the
average school Community that's paid and
monetized on the platform makes in
recurring Revenue per month and so no
this is not a bazillion dollar check
this is not going to get you to be the
richest person in your neighborhood but
can help get you started and so the
tactics that I outlined earlier about
the rule of 300 we're doing this right
now for people inside of school and it's
murdering and so I recommend that you
start because the coolest part of this
whole thing is that you can start
absolutely free and so if that sounds at
all interesting I take a call every
single Monday you can go there
school.com for/ games I'm sure there's
some link somewhere just let me know
that you're new I hop on I answer
questions we walk through through
basically what we saw after studying
thousands of communities that are paid
and doing well and we just tried to
reverse engineer and boil it down to
like what are the actions they took and
so the instructions are very much like
do this x times per day do this y times
per week and if you just follow the
instructions you will get an exceptional
result and so to be clear I stayed in
this box for over a year I just kept
reaching out to people asking for
referrals cuz I didn't even know what
the word advertising really meant I was
just like I'm just going to tell people
that I have this thing and hopefully
they'll want to buy it from me but after
a year of doing stage one talking to
homie stage two getting referral stage
three doing the donation Stuff stage
four that is when I moved on to here all
right which is that I actually made my
first content post and so I'll read it
to you because I think there there's a
lot of actually decent parts to this
post especially like being my first
advertising post ever without being in
this internet marketing world I was just
a consultant in Baltimore everyone for
those of you who know me you know two
things one I'm terrible with all things
technological not that much has changed
for example I just heard about Spotify a
few weeks ago seriously and people at
that point have been had it for like a
decade already two I love training
nutrition and fitness more than well a
lot so today sort of special because it
marks a day where my love of training
vanquished my fear of technology which
by the way many of you should hopefully
get to that day sooner which is that you
should be willing to deal with some
discomfort in order to get what you want
so for the better part of a year I've
been taking part in a free personal
training project with the idea that I
would give away free personal training
to anyone who was willing to give some
of their $500,000 to the cause of their
choice this way they wouldn't have to be
motivated with the same thing as me but
be motivated to give their cause and
benefit themselves when I first
introduced the idea I was happily
surprised with the amount of positive
support I received so almost a year
later for my first client I now have a
website all right to formally show some
of the transformation that have gone
underway using my programming and as a
formal means of contacting me about
setting up basically saying I'm open for
business all right so I put it in caps
I'm currently have a few slots on my
roster uh so drop me a note quickly if
you're interested thanks so much take
out a second to see some of the
ridiculous transformations in record
time check it out that was my post and
that was the post that got me my first
you know 20 or so customers I had been
posting Fitness related stuff for almost
a year but then when I finally was like
Hey I'm open for business that pretty
much like got me the customers I needed
by the way you can actually model this
post to a great degree the intro doesn't
really matter but the main thing was
just kind of want to say what do I mean
CU I probably could have cut the first
part of that post and just say for the
last year I've been doing this which is
just inherent proof and I would like to
make that same offer to you and here's
more proof so if I did it better I would
have probably just been like the images
of the Transformations cuz a lot of
people are not going to make the click
so I want to increase the likelihood
people click or respond and so I
probably would have made it an image
post or a carousel with that and then
the CTA at the bottom saying DM me or
comment or whatever and at the end of
the day we all know that anybody who
likes comments or DMS we're going to
respond to anyways I would just try and
get as much engagement on this post as I
could I would probably text the post and
links to the post to everybody I knew as
well because then that link would
already have all the embedded proof and
notice I didn't have an offer here I
probably would have put an offer in if I
wanted to do what I what I know now but
this is a great place to start which is
proof and some sort of CTA if you put an
off in there it would do better if you
do some sort of bonuses and reverse of
risk you do even better if you say it's
for a certain period of time it does
even better only do that if it's true if
you're if you're like brand new and
you're like have no customers then
probably you'd be willing to take
customers whenever so maybe you don't
say that at first but I said I have a
few slots open which is true but I also
had a lot of slots open I say this
because I'm proud of that kid who
decided to make that move and I think
for many of you you can skip to this
step much faster especially if you
follow the rule of 3 which is just rule
of 100 broken down into three things and
you'll be able to get started a lot
sooner than you think and you can do it
for free like to give you context when
this happened like Instagram was barely
a platform it was like new and it was
just like this image thing like all of
this influencer world like didn't really
exist and so the world's changed it's
never been easier than it is now and in
case you're wondering why I'm in this
narrow hallway believe it or not this is
the narrowest hallway in my 36,000 ft
headquarters but this was supposed to be
as close to as possible as the uh closet
videos that I made at the very beginning
of my YouTube Journey shout out to the
ogs who have been there since those
early days with a webcam so I told you
at the beginning of this video that I'd
be sharing the lessons that I learned
along the way so this isn't like a how
to start your first business obviously
there's things you can model but I think
the the real things are what did this
allow me to learn so that I could move
forward in my journey as an entrepreneur
so the first one is walk the walk and
this kind of always seemed obvious to me
and maybe it's because I was born in the
real world and not the influencer social
media world but like if you're fat it's
going to be hard for you to sell weight
loss if you have Terri teeth it's going
to be hard for you to sell dentist stuff
it's kind of what I call the big obvious
that a lot of people just like choose to
conveniently leave out they're like hey
people aren't buying my investing advice
and it's like yeah cuz you're poor so
maybe don't sell investing advice cuz
obviously it hasn't work you want to be
able to answer the obvious first
objection before you even get it which
is you should be the biggest walking
billboard of whatever it is that you
sell and I was able to succeed without
knowing all the stuff that I know about
offers now and guarantees and reversing
risk and scarcity and urgency and how do
you create value I just knew at least at
the most basic level if I had gotten
results for myself and gotten results
for other people that people would
believe that I could get results for
them at least on some level so I'll also
encapsulate that into proof over promise
it's good to have a promise and it's
good to have proof but if you had to
pick one go for proof now the next thing
that I did in terms of what worked was I
lived cheap all right now the reason
that this is so important in my opinion
is that it allows you to go on the
offensive right like I lived on I think
$1,200 a month at the time and I was
making a consultant's income and I
basically spent no money and saved
everything I had and I had saved up over
the first two years of Consulting about
50 Grand which is not bad for two years
of work like post taxes I was pretty
proud of it and so with that money I was
able to then say you know what I have
the I have the cash to quit my job and
actually go all in on this thing it
still took me like 6 months to do it
don't get me wrong like it was a painful
process cuz I was so afraid but at the
end of the day I had the money and I
knew that I could live on 50 grand for
at least 2 or three years if I had to
saving money won't make you money but
it'll give you the security to think
further out and take bigger risks
because if I had to make money the next
month I would never have been able to
quit my job but I knew that I had two to
three years of Runway that I had bought
myself through saving so that I could
basically give myself more shots on goal
at this point I was a consultant and
made decent money I was able to save 50
after taxes with that income so like I
was living pretty cheap but the big
thing that I did did was I only bought
food at Costco I meal prepped all of my
food I never ate out I didn't go out
which some people might see as sad or
whatever I actually lived right above
the bars of a college town and basically
never went to any of them which was like
weirdly sad for me but anyways that was
it it's I I remember I remember going to
a gym and they said the membership was
$29 a month and I was like a month like
what are you guys crazy and so I went to
a different place that was like 19 or 10
just to show you like how I thought
about money at the time and so I just
didn't spend money like I guess I guess
it was really it it's like I bought food
and I paid rent and that was it it's all
I did and I paid for gas in my car I
didn't buy new clothes I just didn't I
didn't spend money that was all like i'
saved money but just not spending it
that was it and I was working all the
time because I was either working at my
job or the rest of my time I was working
on my next thing and so for me the
biggest hack of all for saving money is
to work more because working more makes
you money in two ways one is you get
paid for the work you do second you
don't have time to spend the money you
make so the next thing that worked was
and this is a big one that a lot of
people somehow like miss out on is start
free all right so I I I did free
honestly probably longer than I should
have or needed to but I was one I didn't
need to make the money yet so I wanted
to give myself a lot of prep a lot of
Runway I kind of haven't changed like
whenever I go into something new like I
want to be overprepared I want to know
I'm going to win if I'm going to do it
and so for me with the start for free
most you guys aren't that good yet and
so the easiest way to get proof is start
free so that you have proof so that you
can show that you walk the walk in that
you have helped other people walk that
walk too here's the cool thing with free
is that there are many things that
someone can do to make you money only
one of them is them giving you money but
if someone gives me a banger testimonial
I will likely make more money from that
testimonial than whatever they paid me
and so think about it if I can guarantee
that that will actually make me more
money just over a longer period of time
and so basically in the beginning you're
stacking yourself with all of these
things that are worth more than the
price you could charge so that you can
cash them in later for money and so
testimonials are worth more feedback is
worth more referrals oftentimes can be
worth more and so all of these things
are things that are non-monetary that
someone can do to compensate you for the
work that you did and so it's not that I
worked uncompensated I just didn't ask
for money I follow Chick-fil-A's
philosophy with pricing it's either full
price or it's free I never discount for
a number of reasons but the biggest one
being I don't negotiate with terrorists
and so the price is the price they
either pay it or they don't and I can
make the decision as a business owner
that okay strategically I'm not getting
the take rates I want I will
strategically lower the price but to
lower the price to get someone to buy
communicates to them and to every single
person they tell that your prices are
not true that everything that you have
is up for negotiation and if you want
the rest of your life to be a haggle by
all means discount people and make
one-off deals for everybody but in my
experience I have a standard price that
I have thought a lot about why I price
at this price and that is what it is
worth to me and if you would do it for
less and you still make money then do it
for Less don't do that but if you want
to go for it I would prefer to say
either our trade is non-monetary it's
free and you will do these things or you
will give me money and I will do all of
these things for you and you don't have
to do any of this stuff and if you
choose to it would be great but I'm not
going to force you to so one of the
other things that worked is that I had a
templated on to many solution so I
worked for you know that year to figure
out what everyone liked eating and so
what I did was I remember spending like
I want to say like 200 hours which was a
huge amount of time for me at the time
on this monster Excel sheet that I could
type in someone's weight their goal Etc
and then it would calculate out the
macros and then the grocery lists for
them for hundred different meals and so
then I could do my consultation with
someone and then like I purposely would
take longer and send it to them like a
week later but it would take me like 10
minutes to prep it and make you know
format it make it look nice and only
select them the meals that I thought
they would like so I had 100 meals I
could pick from and then I would just
pick the ones that I thought they would
be cool they like wow he like really
thought through the grams of every
single one of these meals that they
would add up to my total calorie intake
with the macros ET and so it was very
valuable but it didn't take me a lot of
time and so I think during this free
period is where you invest in the future
you're invest in the future to get
referrals reviews feedback and build out
the okay I keep having these same six
questions okay let me give out really
really like maybe I include that in the
onboarding maybe I make I spend one time
time now so that I never have to do it
again I solve it right so I don't have
to solve it twice I helped a couple
girls lose a lot of weight I helped a
guy lose a lot of weight I helped
another guy lose a decent amount of
weight way and then the rest of the guys
were like recm or getting jacked now
when I did my skinny to swool project
which is where I finally monetized I
can't tell you why but I can tell you
that the thing that everyone responded
to was people who looked like me and who
wanted to look like me and so I ended up
niching without trying into skinny to
swole because that's what I also wanted
to work on like I preferred helping guys
get jacked to helping girls lose weight
niching down can help just because your
Solutions become more templated and so
if everybody's going through the same
goals and having the same starting
position you can provide in real way
more value to them that also Cost You
Less and so it's a double header it cost
you less because everybody has it so you
can template out a lot of it it is more
valuable to them because you're being
way more specific to their problems with
way more depth of solution than if you
had to generically make or personalize
it at a low price for many people you
wouldn't be able to put that much
attention to it it just you couldn't
right unless you charge a lot more which
I recommend and so the next great thing
that I stumbled into was that this was a
recurring business model all right and
so this was something that would pay me
month after month after month now again
I didn't like think through this like oh
what type of I just was like oh well
Fitness a lot of people need to pay me
this month next month and so I just made
a recurring business model to start with
what I made a mistake for was that I
sold 12 weeks and then I didn't sell
them again I went to go find other
customers and so I didn't like have
another offer prepared or say hey you
want to go on maintenance like I didn't
do any of that I was just like cool now
I have to go find another 20 customers
so that was dumb uh but but you love you
learn so that's all the stuff that I
learned that worked well in me making my
first dollars so now we'll go over what
didn't work so the first thing that
didn't work is I didn't Ascend anyone so
I didn't have a second offer or some
sort of way for them to continue to pay
so I would say number one have another
offer now if you're like shoot I don't
know what other offer I would offer them
let me tell you what I should have done
and that you probably should do offer
them more of that thing they just bought
so if they just bought skinny to swo
guess what they probably still want to
be skinny and swo or more swole than
they are so I haven't met a guy who
added 30 pounds to their bench and then
was like I'm good they're like I'll add
another 30 I could go for more right
just make the offer and I just didn't do
it so don't make that mistake the next
thing and this is a big one I stopped
for new so what does that even mean so I
had a business that was making $44,000 a
month in profit online no mad lifestyle
2013 before the internet even [__]
existed not really but before a lot of
these online businesses became kind of
like the Vogue or the norm like there
were basically no like online coach like
that's just was didn't exist and so I
thought that the business I had was not
legit and so I saw my online business
which took me 4 hours a week to do that
was making me $1,000 a week as not legit
compared to me spending all this money
signing a 5-year lease investing into a
brick and mortar location to start a gym
and so I knew that I ultimately wanted
to have a gym because I didn't know
another way that was legit so if I were
coaching me right now I would have been
like wait so you're making $1,000 a week
working 4 hours a week what if you
worked 40 hours a week and made $10,000
a week that would be not that bad and
you'd immediately be in the top 1% of
earning as a 20-some year old working
wherever you want with no like no cost
and why do you not want to do that but
instead I was like oh now that this
worked I should stop doing that
immediately and do something brand new
that I've never done before don't do
that so the next thing that I did that
was messed up is that uh I didn't have a
good offer so I had no offer which was
dumb if I had had an offer I would have
been able to make way more money the
next one is that I had no sale so when I
did this I actually didn't like hop on
the phone I just like literally just
sent people links to buy which was
stupid and I should have got on the
phone because I would have then been
able to charge more right I mean I was
basically offering personalized
everything for $200 a month and part of
the reason that this is going to sound
ridiculous to you if you're listening to
this part of the reason that I I I
probably didn't keep doing the thing it
wasn't making as much money as I wanted
so $4,000 a month like I was like I just
made that doing a consulting job so I'd
want to make more than that and so even
though my first shot immediately matched
what I was making before I didn't think
oh I could just raise my price to make
more money I I was like oh no I should
just start a brand new business like
just dumb but yeah because I didn't have
an offer because I didn't have a sales
script or a sales process I wasn't able
to charge more which then caused me to
stop something that otherwise was an
amazing business I would say the other
thing that I did that was dumb was that
part of the reason that I stopped this
other thing was judgment right and so
I'll explain what I mean by this but
basically you heard me say it like I
didn't think this was legit right like
this isn't a legit business if you sell
a product or service if you exchange
goods and Serv for money you have a
business period so I didn't like Define
terms and like a lot of that stuff came
much later for me but I made really huge
life decisions based on perceived
Judgment of people who weren't even
thinking about me like I was think I
honestly was obsessed about thinking
about what my classmates thought about
me at the time the guys that I like went
to school with I you know I was obsessed
about what my dad would think and all of
this kept me poor and so one of the
biggest mistakes that I made is that
there was no YouTube world that had all
of these like courses and trainings and
videos like this so I didn't get help I
did this all solo which is why I think
it took me a lot longer than it has
taken a lot of people who follow my
stuff and I mean and honestly that's the
point like I hope that like every
generation stands on the shoulders of
the generation before and I hope that
people who are younger than me make more
money than I have made by the time I'm
30 or they're 35 right otherwise it
means that I have failed like I haven't
been able to transfer the knowledge
successfully cuz I'll die no one will
remember me it won't matter and so the
only like real good that I think that
people can do to leave a legacy is to to
pass on the learnings and so that's why
I try to do what I do but I didn't get
help until later and when I got help is
when my you know my income went way up
so I got asked to give advice to a group
of entrepreneurs who were doing this
little test that I was telling you about
on school and they said hey do you have
any like words of advice for everyone
who's starting and so I uh was in a a
writing mood at the time and so I
actually end up sending up this massive
slack message that has now been seen by
like four million people and so I will
share with you right now these are the
directions I told them when they were
starting number one follow instructions
number two When You Reach something you
don't understand how to do Google first
the amount of people who like post
immediately the the moment they have
friction the amount of people who
message me and say hey where do I find
your books I usually just respond where
do you normally find books and then
they're like well Amazon I'm like did
you search people go for an easy button
rather than just like take the Second
Step take the Second Step do the one
Google search before then thinking oh I
will then stop working because that's
basically what happens as soon as you
send a message you I have reached a
point that I cannot cross I've reached a
Chasm to which no man has ever been over
before Google it third when you figure
it out post it other people may have
struggled there too and so this is a way
that you add value in content to
whatever community that you're in four
actually follow the rule of 100 daily
and this is a big one because people get
distracted really really easily and
they're inconsistent and so the thing is
is that their businesses become
inconsistent because they are
inconsistent so businesses themselves
are machines for consistency if you have
consistent inputs you have consist
outputs but if you have inconsistency in
your business it either means that you
are not consistently putting the inputs
in or you need to put more inputs in so
for example if you do 10 reach outs a
day then you might get your one sale
every 10 days it will feel volatile but
it just means that 100 inputs equals one
output so if you want it to be less
volatile then it means that you put
those 100 inputs per day and get one per
day and so really just means that you're
extending the time Horizon on the
results that you want to get so do more
faster more consistently and you will
get more faster consistent results five
you will be excited for a week then the
excitement will off that is when the
work begins and so this is like a key
point that has helped me a lot which is
work starts when excitement ends not
while you're excited I don't even count
it as work while you're excited the work
starts when you have to confront the
reality that you have way more stuff to
do that you don't know how to do and
that's not fun because you will suck
because most people doing things they
don't know how to do aren't good but you
being able to walk that bridge of
discomfort is what will separate you
from the mediocre masses who stop at the
chasm and then just say I don't know
what to do help me six your work works
on you more than you work on it you are
the product that's getting built more
than your community remember this was
for school people so remember that like
you weree the product and so I had this
tweet that got completely bombed and no
one cared about it but I will tell you
what it what it was so I have this
really weird trippy thought the other
day which is in prisoner of war camps
throughout history one of the
psychological torture mechanisms is that
they would have people do manual labor
and one of the particularly nasty ones
is that they would have them dig holes
and then at the end of the day fill the
holes back up and so the point was to
try and Drive the futility and the
meaningless of Life the meaningless of
work and it just breaks them down
psychologically what I found interesting
about that is that every day I go to the
gym and I pick up weights and I put them
exactly back where I was before and so
in both instances there is physical
labor that's happening and everything
looks exactly the way it was but in one
instance it's seen as psychological
torture in the other it seen as
self-care and so it really just means
that these things occur and then we
describe them as labels and so if you
are the asset that is getting built
everything happens for you rather than
to you seven and this is a big one
everything is unscalable in the
beginning that's the point it's how you
learn every single piece of it and when
you learn every single piece of how
something works predictably that's
called Mastery that's how you learn a
skill when you learn lots of skills put
together people are like wow that guy's
good at it that is how you describe
someone who is more skilled and so the
pain that you have to go through when
you're reaching out to all of these
colder prospects not getting responses
what happens is you're like man there
has to be a better way to do this and
then as soon as you do experiment and do
figure out a better way to do it you
have gotten better and so that pain
creates the Catalyst to learn better
ways of doing the same stuff and that's
how in a very real way you gain leverage
skills give you leverage if two people
start the same thing and one gets way
more results that guy did it with more
leverage they did it with more skill and
the pain is the Catalyst to makeing that
happen so don't run away from the pain
run towards the pain learn how to deal
with it by getting better better eight
the pain of repetition is what forces
you to seek Improvement when you figure
out ways to get more for what you do you
have gain skill nine if you complain you
are dead to me not really sure what to
add to that one when you complain you
expend effort for no result And We
complain because we have been rewarded
for complaining in the past and so
rewards typically come in the form of
affection attention and approval meaning
other people pay attention to you they
give you affection say oh I'm sorry
right and sometime they give approval
which in this instance when you do when
you go for pity parties approval doesn't
come but you do get attention and
affection which is why some people like
to be sick because people pay attention
to them they give them affection and so
that's how those Cycles begin but I will
give you a quote that papa heroi gave me
in my Wei days he said it is better to
be envied than pied and so when you
complain functionally the command that
you give your audience is pity me and I
don't know about you but I didn't get in
the game to get pied 10 literally
thousands of people have succeeded you
are not special repeat the same actions
they took to get the same outcomes they
got if you repeat the actions that they
took and you do not get the same
outcomes they got then it means that
there is a variable that you have not
identified yet it doesn't mean that it
doesn't work it means that the way you
did it wasn't the complete way and so if
you build a bridge and there's 10 bricks
across the bridge and you put nine in
you can't say Building Bridges doesn't
work you say I don't know how to build
Bridges the way he builds Bridges I
think he only did these nine steps but
it's clear that he's getting people
across this bridge and I am not so I
have to further study what specific
things he did that I do not do that is
creating the discrepancy between his
outcome and mine 11 write down every
reason that you're going to stick with
it put it in front of you tape it to
your mirror put it behind your laptop
put it wherever you're going to do the
repeated boring work and revisit it when
you need to remember to stick with it
because motivation will fade very
quickly and so having I love this term a
big bag of wi is a great way to remind
you why you need to continue what are
you running away from just as much as
what is your what you're going towards
and in the beginning of this video I
said use what you've got if you're not
super passionate about getting started
but you do know that you hate being
broke you hate your current situation
then write all the things you hate and
say this is why I'm doing this because I
I'm sick of this I don't want this
anymore 12 business is shockingly simple
but surprisingly hard the hard comes in
the form of consistency the moment you
don't want to do it or just skip today
is the day that you realize what hard
actually feels like and that's where you
have to overcome the hard is not in the
complexity what makes it hard is being
consistent that's always like Fitness
isn't hard eat less than you than you
than you burn move more like that's it
right like and add more over time like
it's not complex it's just hard to do
because you have to keep doing it and
you have to keep doing it far before you
see a result for the work you do and so
this is a practice in being able to
further disconnect what you do and what
you get the weakest most impotent people
on Earth are people that must be
immediately rewarded for the work they
do it's how how social media addicts the
masses they get rewarded immediately for
hitting the button for checking their
notification for looking at their likes
for looking at the comments they get
immediate rewards and that is how they
weaken you the people who are the most
potent are able to do big things because
they know it takes a long time to do
them and they will have to work today
for something that will happen a year or
5 years down the road imagine a
competitor that you'd compete against
where one guy has to get a result for
what he does in the moment or he stops
and imagine the other competitor who's
able to do it for a year straight
without seeing a result who do you think
will win obviously the one who Waits a
year be that competitor number 13 just
win because once you win one you'll get
addicted to winning second everything
else that you did to get to there will
fade and so I'll tell you a weird
analogy if you've ever drank too much
and had to throw up and had a whole
night of throwing up when you think back
on it you don't actually remember all
the hours of throwing up you just
remember it kind of sucked a little bit
right like and it and the thing is is
that pain
fades in time so that's a that's
something that is that is behavioral not
just to humans it's across species so
punishment Fades and so the reason that
you get hung over and the next day you
say I'm never drinking again but the
next weekend you go out with your
buddies and drink again is because the
benefit of drinking stays and so the
reason that you have a past relationship
and you're like man I remember the good
old days is because the punishment from
that relationship Fades it's why people
keep revisiting these toxic
relationships they go back and as soon
as you get back into you're like why did
I do this I forgot about this stuff and
so the pain that you are going through
right now will fade but the result that
you get will stay with you and so that
disparity between pain and reward for me
has been one of the biggest unlocks of
life just simply understanding that this
pain will pass but what I get for it
will stay with me an achievement stays
with you for life what it took you to
get there only stays with you in your
mind as long as you choose to give it
attention so that wraps the lessons from
the free training project of how I got
my first customers made my first online
business in the next video you can click
here to learn all the stuff that I
learned from scaling my brick and mortar
gyms and if that video isn't out yet
because we're doing this in sequence
click this video here to learn even more
stuff of bacon dollars